you have to move out of your chair and
catherine is welcome no no she's not
it's not no don't do it trust me don't
do this
don't even say for the queen you can't
don't say for the queen for the queen
no i don't see that please are you a
gardener do you like to garden not
unless that's some dreadful euphemism
you cheeky monkey no no no
no i don't know what's wrong with you i
understand everything he's not
because you're looking at him when you
don't see him and you don't see the
lipstick
stop saying he i'm present
that's the problem with current affairs
you forget about what's important you
allow the agenda to be decided by
superficial information
what am i saying what am i talking about
don't think about what i'm wearing these
things are redundant i'm superficial
okay don't be distracted what do you
think that gesture means the way you're
touching that ball what does that
indicate
what is that what's the subtext of that
we gotta go to break you need to lose
that ring
because it doesn't mean nothing to you
is that clean from drugs and alcohol
what about sex addiction
yeah what about that shagger of the year
now listen
you'll let me strip to my title i'll
have you stripped to your tights
but being a child that should be an
award enough you're free of
responsibility
you can do what you want you're not
tortured by pubic
ideas that's not what's wrong with that
i don't know i just i never heard
someone say pubic ideas before
well stick around baby because i'm going
to say it later
what do do people think that there's
something going on i mean do you
ever meet people who are have an
unreasonable
fascination well i think there is no
such thing as unreasonable fascination
it's such a wonderful concept to be
fascinated
one of the key inspirations behind this
very haircut was a gentleman i met
called
rail rail runs an extraterrestrial cult
he believes that aliens
don't judge him for that other than the
worship of extraterrestrials he's a very
down-to-earth man
he says that aliens can communicate
messages to us
through our hair so i thought take that
to its natural conclusion
try and reach out to them a little bit
it's not all one-way traffic well that's
right
i think you're doing us a favor perhaps
i might be i've not received any signals
as yet david other than a very clear one
from
humans of get your hair cut well
you have to go okay russell oh
um it's like your desk is a puzzle it is
i'm sorry about that what is the
solution
i think we could try and pull it back in
be careful because that's a low-cut
dress oh sorry okay
um i'm only flesh and blood i've got
instincts oh
okay well tell me what you need to know
um
i'm just gonna have a drink here you
actually
you played actually because we're
talking about sex and shag you playing
nice thank you so much i appreciate it i
like these
sort of gladiator high up shoes you're
wearing and i like your legs now i
understand you've been celibate for a
while when you're gonna give that up
there are some spores on this wow spores
airborne spores i'll place it here
it's not as vulgar these are life-giving
seeds from another dimension
i assure you this is an area in which
i'm confident i am not bluffing
i i will take care of you i will make
you see multi-colored i'll make you
forget your own name and personally i am
of course
in spite of appearances i'm a
heterosexual man congratulations
and the uh people think because i'm so
well dressed people think he must be gay
no no
look at his wonderful haircut he must be
gay look how sensitive and vulnerable he
is
he must be gay that's great that means
women feel safe around me
they trust me then bang pregnant bang
pregnant bang pregnant
you know she may be a queen that she may
well be but she's also
buxom in the boob department and i
thought
what a way to distinguish myself if i
were to suddenly
landed her god bless you mom
my this is my first um brand experience
brand
yeah i think it's not listening to them
it's it's it's experience it's just sort
of taking it all in
you are talking about me as if i'm not
here and as if i'm an extraterrestrial
you know i'm from a country that's near
dummy we're just sort of admiring the
whole you know it's the whole thing
well thank you for your casual
objectification it's an experience
i'm glad that it is positive for you
very positive absolutely
anymore any other questions you've
become nervous
why are you nervous you're a powerful
woman you've got a lovely job what seems
to be the trouble
you've got a hair like princess diana oh
wow okay
depressing i would think to know your
place in the hierarchy because you'd
think oh
if that one dies then it's me so death
is a necessary part
of your ascension a bit depressing
wouldn't it i guess it would weigh on
your mind a little bit yes
like were you to perish then you would
become
in charge
yes you thinking about something yeah as
a matter of fact i was thinking about
something because as you know i've
announced it i find catherine very
attractive
then when she said exchanged numbers i
thought things i'd like to exchange with
her
number and jeans is happening
[Music]
hello wendy williams how are you you've
got a
sticker on your pants forgive me that
was a misdemeanor that's just to
restrain myself if necessary we managed
to get tickets
uh for the super bowl fun and when i say
we i mean my husband
yeah but you you know look at the way
you dropped the jets you could drop that
guy any day
[Music]
mine is very simple i just have a simple
band but yours is very beautiful it's
rather elaborate because i was wed in
india
and there was a element of glamour to
the proceedings plus i'm a bit of a
popinjay a magpie i'm attracted by
sparkly things bejeweled things
in a minute you'll look for your watch
and you'll find it's in my pocket
[Applause]
complimentary yeah sorry
about that take your time we got nothing
to do
uh
what did uh oh lord
and they're taking wrestling out what do
you mean the olympics were removing
wrestling like it was a bad
tooth and what bases well they say it's
not a sport it's just cuddling with no
clothes on
if there was an olympic medal for that
then i should be surely adorned
i don't know gold silver bronze
what were you before you got clean as
they say
dave 11 years ago when i was still
taking drugs i was a whirling psychotic
a frequenter of crack houses [ __ ]
houses i was a lunatic i was ever in
jail cells
i was forever in all sorts of mischief
and murph spraying blood everywhere
broken glass crying women everywhere i
went but some nights i just stayed in
have you ventured onto the freeway yet
yeah you have
it's the freeway is the crack cocaine of
driving yes yes it is
oh my god it's happening yeah yeah if i
just did that we'd all
die sometimes it's too much power you
know like sometimes like to know that
all i have to do is that
and i'll cause chaos that's i have to
resist that because say sometimes you're
drinking hot tea
and you're with like a little old lady
don't you sometimes think
in your mind i could at any moment just
go get you you know what exactly
but the possibility exists and that is
why i will never be meeting the queen
again
i'm not in the porn industry i don't
know why i'm saying that in the
in the olympic village i didn't think
you were coming in that class
eventually we would merge what you and i
well if we just kept moving closer and
closer to each other
andy could hug us into one glorious
ectoplasm of man
have you heard of any accident did you
bump anything in i knocked over what uh
in my country we call bins but you call
pedestrians
wow but when you actually meet her all
them words are ringing in your ears it's
brought terrible pressure and part of my
mind is always against me look at this
haircut
that part of my mind that part of my
mind toning whilst i'm trying to think
caller
ma'am as in jam not from the waist a
mama's
part of me thinking grab her boobs
what i think you've done is you've
tyrannized me with your masculinity but
there is an air of femininity to you
like you're like a perverse hybrid like
a female bodybuilder like a
person that's neither one thing or
another like a hermaphrodite with a new
genital in your armpit
no i say it's time for a bloody
revolution
no really yeah people some people are
into it
not really no no you've got like
you've got three people so what only
takes one to chop off someone's head